THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARILLO.
CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALY [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible] EIGHT MEN FLORA.
FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE.
LOW MOAN [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WICKS.
WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
SPEECH IN NORTH [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
AS WE PREPARE TO CONCLUDE THE
BUSINESS OF A BUSY WEEK AND
APART FROM A MORAL DAY WEEKENDS
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THIS MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
MEMORIAL DAY HONORS AND
REMEMBERS THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
HAVE DIED WHILE SERVING IN THE
ARMED FORCES OF THE UNITED
STATES.
MEN AND WOMEN WHO PAID THE
ULTIMATE SACRIFICE TO DEFEND OUR
LIBERTY.
OUR FREEDOM.
OUR AMERICAN VALUES.
TODAY WITH OUR HEADS TO GIVE
THANKS.
WITH OUR HEADS TO PRAY FOR THE
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
LEFT BEHIND.
AND WHOSE HEARTS CONTINUE TO
BREAK.
WITHOUT OUR HEADS TO HONOR THEIR
SACRIFICE.
AND TO TRULY HONOR THEIR
SACRIFICE AND THEIR MEMORY.
WE MUST DO MORE THAN SIMPLY BOW
OUR HEADS.
LORD.
MAY WE HONOR THESE AMERICAN
HEROES IN THE LIVES WE LEAD AND
IN THE WORK THAT WE DO.
OUR COMMITMENT TO AMERICA'S
IDEALS.
IN OUR BELIEF THAT WE ARE ALL
CREATED EQUAL.
THAT WE ARE ALL ENTITLED TO LIFE.
TO AND THE PURSUIT OF HAPPINESS.
AND MAY WE HONOR THESE AMERICAN
HERE AS BY SEIZING THIS DAY AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REJECT
DIVISION.
AND TO PRAY FOR UNITY.
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS A
MORE PERFECT UNION.
AND A MORE PERFECT STATE.
MAY WE REMEMBER.
THAT WE HAVE MORE IN COMMON THAN
WE DO AT ODDS.
AND THAT THE TIES THAT BIND US
TOGETHER.
ARE MUCH STRONGER THAN THE
FORCES THAT WOULD SEEK TO
TERRACE APART [inaudible]
LORD.
GIVE US IN THIS CHAMBER AND
ACROSS THIS NATION WITH STAN.
STRENGTH.
AND MERCY [inaudible]
A MAN.
THANK YOU MISS BETWEEN ARRESTS
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER RE
OF US AS SHE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
THANK YOU -- PLEASE JOIN ME AND
SALUTING THE FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
TO THE REPUBLIC. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD.
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY MAY
SIXTEENTH TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
ONLY MINUTE NINE AM ON A BED OF
OUR QUE HAN ASSISTANCE BEAKER
PRO TEM OF THE SIMPLY PRESIDING
CHEAPER DEDUCTIBLES IN AT THE
DESK.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
MELENDEZ SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR
ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY
AND FOR A DEATH IN THE FAMILY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW SOMETHING
MEMBERS.
RAMOS LACKEY CARILLO TO SPEAK ON
A GERMAN MEMBER TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I MOVE
TO SUSPEND JOINT ROLE TWENTY
EIGHT TO ONE TWENTY EIGHT POINT
ONE IN TWENTY NINE TO REMIT THE
APPOINTMENT OF FIVE CONFEREES TO
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
ON AB SEVENTY FOUR RELATING TO
THE BUDGET ACT.
TWENTY NINETEEN MEMBERS THIS IS
THIS IS A MOTION TO SUSPEND THE
JOINT RULES AND IT REQUIRES A
ROLL CALL VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE [inaudible]
MR.
MR FLOORS ASKING FOR NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND MISTER FLOOR IS ASKING FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THIS IS SUPPORT SUPPORT BOTH
MISTER CALDERON IN MISTER FLOOR
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTES
[inaudible]
A LITTLE.
MR FLORA IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I MOVE
TO CORRECT THE COMMITTEE REPORT
ON HR THIRTY SIX MIN.
IN ORDER THE RESOLUTION TO THE
FIRST DAY CONSENT CALENDAR THE
RESOLUTION WAS MISTAKENLY
REPORTED TO THIRD READING
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES TO
ALLOW SOME MEMBER GONZALEZ. TO
TAKE UP LATE AMENDMENTS TO ITEM
THIRTY SIX AB FIVE WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE CHAMBER TODAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA.
HAS GAS THAT WE'D LIKE TO
WELCOME TO THE CHAMBER THEIR
HERE TODAY IN CONJUNCTION WITH A
YOUNG WORKER SAFETY MAN WELCOME
TO OUR CHAMBER.
MISTER GALLAGHER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE THE RICE.
YES MISS SPEAKER I MOVED TO RE
REFER HR TWENTY TWO FROM THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE.
THAT MOTION IS THE SECOND IS
THERE A SECOND TIME MOTION THIS
MELENDEZ SECONDS THE MOTION.
MISTER CALDERON OF JACK'S.
TAKES FORTY ONE VOTES.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I BELIEVE I GET TO THE DEBATE
THAT MOTION -- SKEWS ME MISTER
GALLAGHER STRIKE THE ROLE MISTER
GALLAGHER LIKE TO SPEAK ON THE
MOTION MISTER.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU MAY SPEAK
BUT ONLY TO THE PROPRIETY OF THE
MOTION.
VERY BRIEFLY MADAM SPEAKER THIS
IS SIMPLY A BILL THAT CONDEMNS
THE UC DAVIS PROFESSOR FOR
CALLING FOR THE KILLING OF
POLICE OFFICERS AND TO SHOOT
THEM IN THE BACK.
I WANT THIS TO GO TO RULES
COMMITTEE SO IT CAN BE HEARD IT
IT IS NOT BEING HEARD AND HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE I'D LIKE
IT'S GOT A RULES COMMITTEE SO
THAT WE CAN ALL UNIVERSALLY
CONDEMN.
THESE STATEMENTS AS A BODY THANK
YOU.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE.
MR FLOOR IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
TAKES FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTERS.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR NO
DEBT VOTE AND MISTER FLORES
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTEEN KNOWS.
FORTY TWO THAT MOTION FAILS
YES
ON THE DAILY FILE [inaudible]
THIRD.
READING FILE ITEM TO TEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY NEW
AGRICULTURE EMPLOYEE HOUSING.
MR RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND I AM VERY VERY PROUD.
TO STAND FOR ALL OF YOU THIS
MORNING AT PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THIS BILL.
IS A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD.
IN ADDRESSING OUR FARM WORKER
HOUSING SHORTAGE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND CERTAINLY IN
ASSEMBLY -- IN THE SOME OF THIS
AND I REPRESENT.
FARMWORKERS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
ECONOMY.
AND TOGETHER WITH OUR FAMILY
FARMERS.
THEY WORK TO BRING THE FRESHEST
PRODUCE TO MARKET.
AND CERTAINLY DO THEIR PART IN
HELPING FEED THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
YET THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE DECENT PLACES FOR
THEM TO LIVE.
SOME ARE HOMELESS.
OTHERS PAY RENT.
AND THAT EATS UP THE MAJORITY OF
THEIR FAMILIES ENTIRE PAY.
AND THERE HOUSING.
THEIR LIVING SITUATION.
STOP LARA WILL.
WE HAVE FARMWORKERS LIVING IN
GARAGES [inaudible]
INTENSE.
IN VANS.
AND ABANDONED BUILDINGS.
WE HAVE A MULTIPLE FAMILIES
LIVING IN THE SAME ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
THERE ARE FARMWORKERS LIVING IN
TRAILERS.
WITH NO AIR CONDITIONING NO AIR
CONDITIONING DURING THE HOT
SUMMER MONTHS.
THESE AREN'T JUST FARMWORKERS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IT'S THEIR CHILDREN [inaudible]
THEIR FAMILIES.
IN RURAL MONTEREY COUNTY.
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT ONE
IN TEN STUDENTS [inaudible]
ARE HOMELESS.
IN TWELVE SCHOOLS.
THAT NUMBER IS ONE IN.
FIVE A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
THESE KIDS.
OUR CHILDREN OF FARMWORKERS.
THIS IS HAPPENING RIGHT HERE.
IN THE GOLDEN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA WHICH RANKS AS THE
WHICH NOW RANKS AS THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE ENTIRE
WORLD.
FARMWORKERS ENSURE THAT PLACES
LIKE GOOGLE [inaudible]
APPLE FACEBOOK.
CAN ALL HAVE ENDLESS SUPPLIES OF
FOOD IN THE CAFETERIA.
YET THE SAME FARM FARM WORKERS
DO NOT HAVE A SAFE AND DECENT
ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS
[inaudible]
THIS SITUATION.
IS A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT WE HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION IN THE MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO ACT.
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE IS AN
IMPORTANT FIRST STEP.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD CREATE AN
OPT IN PROGRAM A TOOL.
DESIGNED TO STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS BY WHICH DECENT QUALITY
FORMER HOUSING GETS BILL.
IT DOES NOT ADD ADDITIONAL RED
TAPE FOR OUR FARMERS.
INSTEAD IT HELPS MAKE IT EASIER
FOR FARMERS.
AND NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
BUILD THE DIGNIFIED FAMILY
FRIENDLY HOUSING. FOR WORKERS
WHO KEEP US FED AND HELP DRIVE
OUR STATE ECONOMY.
THIS BILL WON'T SOLVE ALL OF OUR
PROBLEMS WITH REGARD TO FARM
WORKER HOUSING AND OUR FORMER
HOUSING SHORTAGE.
BECAUSE THERE'S MUCH MORE WORK%
TO BE DONE AROUND THIS ISSUE.
BUT IT IS AN IMPORTANT FIRST
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
SO AS MANY OF YOU KNOW I CAN
SPEAK ABOUT THIS ISSUE I CAN
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FORMER HOUSING.
AND I COULD SPEAK ABOUT IT FROM
FROM FROM FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE.
YOU SEE MY GRANDFATHER WAS A
FARMWORKERS ALMADEN VINEYARDS A
PIE SI NOUS.
RIGHT HERE CALIFORNIA.
HE WITH MY GRANDMOTHER AND MY
MOM WAS A SINGLE PARENT THEY
RAISED MY BROTHER AND I AND I
GREW UP IN FORMER HOUSING WITH
TEN MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY.
IN OUR HOUSING WAS VERY VERY
BASIC BUT IT WAS DECENT.
AND OUR ROLE OF FARM WORKER
HOUSING.
WAS LOCATED RIGHT BESIDE THE
VINEYARDS WHEN MY GRANDFATHER
WENT IN WORK EVERY SINGLE DAY
[inaudible]
DECENT HOUSING.
OUR DECENT FARM WORKER HOUSING.
IT GAVE OUR FAMILY THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BETTER LIFE.
BUT MANY FARMWORKERS THEN AND
TODAY ARE NOT SO LUCKY.
THIS BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE WILL MAKE
A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN THE
LIVES OF THOSE WHO WORK THE
FEELS LIKE MY GRANDFATHER DID.
AND WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
CURRENT GENERATION OF
FARMWORKERS.
THAT THEIR CHILDREN ALSO HAVE
THE CHANCE AT A BETTER LIFE AND
A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
SO ON BEHALF OF MY CO AUTHORS.
I RESPECTFULLY RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
YES THANK YOU MEMBERS MEMBERS I
RISE ALSO TO SUPPORT AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE NOW I'M
NOT A GIRL FROM THE FARMS AND MY
PARENTS DID NOT.
COME ACROSS THE BORDER BUT MY
GRANDPARENTS WERE HERE AND FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE OFTEN
DON'T TALK ABOUT FARMWORKERS ARE
HOW WE EVEN GET OUR PRODUCE.
BUT AS A TEACHER FOR THIRTY
YEARS I TOO HAVE SEEN STUDENTS
WHOSE FAMILIES HAVE MOVED OVER
AND OVER WHO HAVE BEEN PULLED
OUT OF SCHOOL BECAUSE THEIR
FAMILIES ARE MOVING FOR THE NEXT
JOB.
AND WHETHER IT'S FARM WORKER
HOUSING OR SENIOR HOUSING OR
STUDENT HOUSING WE HAVE A MORAL
OBLIGATION AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO START TO SAY YES
TO SAY YES TO HOUSING YES TO THE
EMERGENCY SHELTERS WE NEED.
YES TO THE STUDENTS PARKING IN
OUR COLLEGE PARKING LOTS AND YES.
TO THE DECENT TYPE OF HOUSING
THAT TYPE OF HOUSING THAT
SOMEONE CAN GET UP IN THE
MORNING AND WASH THEIR FACE AND
HAVE BREAKFAST AND GO OFF TO
SCHOOL TO LEARN.
THE TYPE OF HOUSING WHERE THEY
WANT TO BRING THEIR FRIENDS HOME
IN TOO MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
WHETHER IT'S FROM THE NORTH OR
THE SOUTH OFTEN COME TO SCHOOL.
WITHOUT THEIR UNIFORMS WITHOUT
CLEAN CLOTHES BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE MEANS SO
NOT A LOT DO I. SUPPORT YOUR
FARM WORKER HOUSING BUT I
SUPPORT ALL HOUSING.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE THANK YOU
MISS WORK SELMA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MYSTERY
THIS WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
AGAIN JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY SIX
NO THREE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN AB EIGHTEEN
OH EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL EIGHTEEN OH EIGHT BY
THE COMMITTEE ON JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND THE ECONOMY
ACTUALLY THE SMALL BUSINESSES.
CERVANTES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ABA TUNE -- EIGHT
STRAIGHT INTO TV B. E. PROGRAM
BY REQUIRING THE CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE CALVERTS
PROGRAM ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THE PROGRAM.
THIS NEW SUPPORT BY THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATE ADDS WEIGHT
AND IMPORTANCE TO CAL THAT'S
WORK ON THE DVB PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER ON TASTE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
THE ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT INTO TWELVE AB FORTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
AS ONLY WILL FORTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER O'DONNELL AND
OTHERS NATALIE THE EDUCATION
FINANCE BY PROVIDING THE FUNDS
NECESSARY THERE.
FOR AN ELECTION FOR THE ISSUANCE
OF THE SALE OF BONDS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR THE
HANDLING OF THE DISPOSITION OF
THESE FUNDS.
MR O'DONNELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AB FORTY EIGHT IS A
VEHICLE FOR A K. FOURTEEN SCHOOL
FACILITIES BOND TO BE PRESENTED
TO VOTERS.
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE K. TWELVE US IN
THE K. TWELVE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM IS A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
THAT IS BASED ON A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND DEVELOPERS.
STATE BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN
MATCHED BY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN LOCAL BOND FUNDS AND
DEVELOPER FEES [inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
TOGETHER THESE FUNDS HAVE BUILT
NEW SCHOOLS MODERNIZE AGING
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THEY ARE
SAFE AND UPDATED.
AND SUPPORTED VOCATIONAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
THESE FUNDS.
ALSO HELP THE ECONOMY BY
GENERATING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
JOBS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OVER THE LAST TWENTY YEARS
VOTERS HAVE SUPPORTED MULTIPLE
STATE BONDS FOR SCHOOLS THE LAST
ONE PROPOSITION FOR FIFTY ONE
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN WAS PAST TEN
YEARS.
AFTER THE PRIOR BONE.
DUE TO THE LENGTHY GAP NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND MODERNIZATION
FUNDS FOR PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE
ARE ALREADY DEPLETED.
IN FACT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN APPLICATIONS HAVE
BEEN SUBMITTED BEYOND THE
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE FUNDING
AVAILABILITY.
THE NEED IS GREAT.
IN ADDITION TO THE BASIC
PROGRAMS NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND CHARTER SCHOOLS.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES MORE RECENT
NEEDS INCLUDING.
PROVIDING FACILITIES FOLLOWING A
DISASTER.
REMEDIATION OF LEAD IN WATER
FOUNTAINS.
REPLACEMENT OF SEVENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD BUILDINGS.
PRESCHOOL'S AT SCHOOL SITES AND
ASSISTANCE FOR SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
WE ALL KNOW FACILITIES MATTER IN
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
AND STUDENT MOTIVATION IN FACT
SCHOOL FACILITIES SET THE TONE
FOR THE SCHOOL DAY WHEN A
STUDENT WALKS IN.
THIS BILL HAS NUMEROUS
SUPPORTERS AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE
RISE AS A CO AUTHOR THIS MEASURE.
LET'S GIVE VOTERS THE OPTION THE
CHOICE TO INVEST IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE HAVE NEEDS FOR CAREER TECH
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS AND SHOPS
THAT COSTS MONEY THESE ARE NOT.
THIRTY DESKS AND TEXTBOOKS THESE
ARE SHOPS.
THEY REQUIRE A QUICK MINUTE IT
COSTS MONEY.
AND WE'VE GOT A HUGE SKILLS GAP
IN THE UNITED STATES IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE BABY BOOMERS ARE RETIRING
OUT OF SKILLED TRADES EVERY
SINGLE DAY THERE'S A ESTIMATED
FIVE MILLION OPEN JOBS FOR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE A SKILL.
WE NEED THE CLASSROOMS TO TRAIN
THOSE KIDS.
IN THE CAREER TECHNICAL FIELD.
WE NEED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION CLASSROOMS AND
FACILITIES.
LET'S GIVE VOTERS THE OPTION TO
INVEST IN THAT I ASKED FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE MISTER O'DONNELL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THAT'S RIGHT I HAVE A MINISTRY
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
WHEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOMES
MORE VISITORS SO FLORA HAPPEN
MISTER CUNNINGHAM I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME STUDENTS FROM CAPPY
COLDER ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
WELCOMED -- CHAMBER.
FILE ITEMS TO THIRTEEN TO
FOURTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY FIGHT
A ITEM TO FIFTEEN AB NINE THIRTY
ONE THE CLERK WILL READ THAT'S
ONLY ONE NINE THIRTY ONE BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURNER FOR BATH
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOARDS.
MISPRINT OR BACK YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
YES MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
NINE THIRTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE
THE COMPOSITION OF EACH
APPOINTED.
LOCAL BOARDING COMMISSION --
WITH FIFTY AND CITIES WITH --
FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE MORE
WITH AT LEAST FIVE APPOINTED
MEMBERS TO HAVE BY 203050% WOMEN.
WHILE WOMEN IN MAY THAT
CONSIDERABLE ADVANCES IN THE
WORK FORCE IN RECENT YEARS THEY
STILL FACE INEQUITIES AND OFTEN
PREVENT THEM FROM REACHING THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL. FOR EXAMPLE
WOMEN TO THE STATE REMAIN VASTLY
UNDER REPRESENTED ON APPOINTED
LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS AND
CALIFORNIA'S GOVERNMENT AND IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
AND ENCINITAS WHEN I SERVED ON
THE PLANNING COMMISSION I WAS
ONE THE ONLY WOMAN ON THIS BOARD.
AND NOW THAT I'M HERE IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY I AT THE BORDERS
ALL MEN.
ANOTHER CALL YOU RECENTLY SURE
THAT WON'T LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHE
WAS TOLD SHE COULD NOT BE ON THE
PLANNING COMMISSION AS A WOMAN
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
LEADERSHIP POSITION.
THAT OFTEN CAN LEAD TO HIGHER
OFFICE.
WELL THIS POLICY OF THE STATE IS
THE GENERAL PUBLIC CAN BE
REPRESENTED WITH THE COMPOSITION
OF STATE BOARD THE COMMISSION.
THERE IS NO POLICY THAT GOVERNS
LOCAL BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
WITHOUT FAIR REPRESENTATION ON
THE LAW WOMEN WHO WORTH 52% OF
THE CALIFORNIA STRUGGLE TO CHIU
FAIR AND EQUAL REPRESENTATION
WITHIN THE VERY SPORTS
COMMISSION.
THAT GOVERNMENTS OF OUR DAILY
LIVES AB NINE THIRTY ONE SEEMS
TO NEARLY TAYLOR -- EXISTING
GENDER DISPARITIES IN
APPOINTMENTS ON LOCAL.
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS BY
REQUIRING THAT THEY HAVE EQUAL
REPRESENTATION OF MY MEN AND MEN
AND WOMEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS BOERNER HORVATH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS FIVE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID.
MR MEDINA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB.
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IS
OUTDATED AN OVERLY COMPLEX WITH
TOO MANY BARRIERS TO ACCESS.
STATE AID DOES NOT ADEQUATELY
SERVE TODAY'S COLLEGE STUDENTS
AND DOES NOT REFLECT THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING.
OF CALIFORNIA.
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
COME TO MY OFFICE ON AN ALMOST
WEEKLY BASIS SHARING THEIR
STORIES OF HOUSING AND FOOD IN
SECURITY.
STUDENTS DO OFTEN DO NOT KNOW
WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL WILL COME
FROM.
SOMETIMES THEY DO NOT EVEN KNOW
WHERE THEY WILL SLEEP FOR THE
NIGHT.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM -- ORANGE
COUNTY ALLUDED TO EARLIER.
I WILL ALSO NOTE THAT IT IS TRUE
FOR ALL OF THE THREE SEGMENTS OF
OUR PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
STUDENTS AND THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE CSU AND UC FACE
THESE CHALLENGES.
AND THESE ARE CHALLENGES THAT
THOSE STUDENTS SHOULD HAVE TO
FACE.
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL AID
REFORM IS NEEDED TO MAKE OUR
SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE AND ENSURE
THAT MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE DEGREE.
AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN EXPANDS THE
EXISTING CAL GRANT SYSTEM TO
HELP COVER NON TUITION COSTS FOR
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS.
IT REMOVES BARRIERS TO ACCESS
SUCH AS AGE RESTRICTIONS TIME
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL AND
DOCUMENTATION STATUS.
CONSOLIDATING AND SIMPLIFYING
THE PROGRAM INTO ONE AWARD.
AND ADDS COVERAGE FOR SUMMER
SCHOOL CLASSES.
THIS BILL IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS.
FROM THE BEGINNING THE PROCESS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO I
WHEEZE AS WE FLESH OUT THE
DETAILS OF THIS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES THAT STAND WITH ME IS
JOINT AUTHORS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
YES THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
SPEAKER I AM PROUD JOIN AUTHOR
WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR FRANKLY.
THREE OR FOUR YEARS NOW AND THE
ISSUE OF OF COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY IS ONE WE ALL KNOW.
AND WE TALK ABOUT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ALL THE TIME.
SURE IT WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE
FREE COLLEGE IN OUR GREAT STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I'M NOT SURE IF
THAT'S AFFORDABLE BUT REALLY WE
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THAT HOW
WE CAN MAKE COLLEGE.
DEBT FREE.
THE NOT SO THIS BILL IS ABOUT
REFORMING OUR CAL GRANT IN
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAMS TO SIMPLIFY THEM YOU
LITERALLY NEED A DEGREE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO APPLY FOR
THESE.
CALTRAIN A MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAMS.
THERE ARE EXCLUSIONS AFTER
EXCLUSION AS FAR AS WHO DOES NOT
APPLY WITH THIS BILL DOES IS TRY
TO SIMPLIFY IT AND WHY IN THE
POT SO EVERYBODY IS ABLE TO
APPLY.
IF THEY ARE ENROLLED AN ELIGIBLE
TO GO TO A YOU SEE CSU OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
THERE ARE OTHER COSTS OF CALLED
AS WE KNOW AS WELL NOT JUST
TUITION ANYMORE THE AVERAGE DEBT
FOR SOMEONE FROM THE CSU AND UC
SYSTEM IS NORTH OF TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
SO THAT LIMITS OUR ABILITY WHEN
THEY GRADUATE TO CERTAINLY HERE
WITH MILLENNIALS TODAY. TO BUY A
HOME START A FAMILY SAVE FOR
THEIR RETIREMENT AND SO FORTH SO.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE FOCUS ON
THE TRUE COST OF COLLEGE.
AND BEFORE US WE HAVE A PLAN
WHICH WOULD DO THAT.
THE NOT SOMETHING WE CAN DO
OVERNIGHT CERTAINLY A MULTI YEAR
EFFORT WE ARE STARTING THAT
EFFORT IN THE STATE BUDGET.
THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET THAT WE ARE
GOING TO A RATIFIED LATER TODAY
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE.
HAS A YEAR ONE OF IMPLEMENTATION
FOR THIS GREAT PLAN AND AGAIN I
RISE IN SUPPORT AND THIS WILL
HELP MORE FAMILIES MORE
CALIFORNIANS AFFORD HIGHER
EDUCATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CARTY MISS MELENDEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THIS BILL TAKES
THE CAL GRANT AWARD PROGRAM IN
THE MIDDLE CLASS STUDENT
SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM AND COMBINES
THEM INTO ONE WHICH MEANS WE ARE
GETTING RID OF THE MIDDLE CLASS
STUDENT SCHOLARSHIP AWARD WHICH
SHOULD BE VERY CONCERNING. TO
ALL OF US IT'S NOT THAT WE AS A
BODY DON'T WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS HAVE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION HAVE
SOME HELP ALONG THE WAY.
BUT GETTING RID OF A VERY
IMPORTANT -- SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
FOR MIDDLE CLASS STUDENT MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
VERY LIKELY WILL BE SHUT OUT OF
THIS PROCESS IS NOT.
IS THAT FAIR TO THEM WHO ARE
WORKING HARDER KEEPING THEIR
HEADS ABOVE WATER.
WHO ARE TRYING TO DO THE BEST
THEY CAN FOR THEIR KIDS IS IT?
IS NOT WHAT YOU WANTED TO DO
WANT TO CUT THEM OUT OF THIS
PROCESS I I HAD.
GREAT CONCERN WITH HOW THIS BILL
IS STRUCTURED IN THAT IT DOES
CUT THEM OUT AND I WOULD.
ASK YOU TO EXERCISE CAUTION.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
MISTER MEDINA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES.
OUR LEGISLATION ACTUALLY
MAINTAINS THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP BUT PUTS IT INTO ONE
PROGRAM.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO --
STATING YOU ALMOST NEED A PHD OR
MORE TO BE ABLE TO NAVIGATE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM SO WHAT WE'VE
HEARD FROM MANY MANY STUDENTS.
IS THAT WE NEED A MORE SIMPLE
USER FRIENDLY -- SYSTEM AND THIS
IS WHAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MEDINA THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY ONE
KNOWS YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS TO SEVENTEEN TO
EIGHTEEN PASS TEMPORARILY.
FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN AB EIGHT
NINETY ONE THE CLERK WILL READ
AS A LEGAL EIGHT NINETY ONE BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THIS BURKE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS EIGHT
NINETY ONE REQUIRE CITIES AND
COUNTIES WITH POPULATIONS
GREATER THAN THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND TO ESTABLISH A
SAFE PARKING PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES SAFE PARKING LOCATIONS.
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN
THEIR VEHICLES THESE LOCAL
PROGRAMS WHILE THE FLEXIBILITY
TO ESTABLISH RULES AND
REGULATIONS FOR THE PROGRAM THAT
THAT LOCAL NEEDS AS WELL AS AN
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT CAN
INCLUDE A BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PARTICIPANTS.
PROGRAMS CREATE UNDER THIS BILL
WILL ALSO BE ENCOURAGED TO CORNY
WITH LOCAL NONPROFITS AS WELL AS
SITTING COUNTY AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE THE RESOURCES AND ACCESS
TO SOCIAL SERVICES.
THAT LEAD TO LONG TERM HOUSING
AB EIGHT NINETY ONE TWO BC AS A
COMPLEMENTARY TO CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING EFFORTS TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE WHO ARE LIVING IN
THEIR VEHICLES HAVE A SAFE PLACE
TO STAY OVERNIGHT WELL THEY WORK
TO TERMS THE TRANSITION TO MORE
PERMANENT HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I'VE OF THANK YOU
MISS BURKE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS.
MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR
OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ROADSIDE ABOUT THIS
REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY
TO NEWS THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO THIRTY TWO
A. B. TEN FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ AS A LEGAL TEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW MOAN
AND ACTUALLY THE OIL AND GAS.
MS LIMON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY OIL AND GAS WELLS THIS
FIGURE INCLUDES APPROXIMATELY
THIRTY THOUSAND IDLE WELLS.
MANY OF WHICH HAVE BEEN IDLE FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AND POST
A HIGH RISK FOR DESERTION.
AS OIL PRODUCTION CONTINUES TO
DECLINE IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS A
GROWING CONCERN OVER THE IMPACT
THAT DESERTED OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURES COULD HAVE.
LEAVING TAXPAYERS TO ADDRESS THE
RISK AND COVER THE COST.
BASED ON CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES
COSTS TO TAXPAYERS COULD BE AS
HIGH AS TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
EIGHT MILLION PER TEN THOUSAND
OIL WELLS.
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE THE RECENT
BANKRUPTCY IS TO OIL COMPANIES
WILL COST TAXPAYERS OVER A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
OIL AND GAS PRODUCERS ALREADY
ACCEPT THE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PLUG WALLS WHEN THEY ENTER INTO
LEASES WITH THE STATE TO DRILL.
IN ORDER TO INSURE THAT THEY
FULFILL THIS OBLIGATION ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN FIFTY SEVEN WILL
STRENGTHEN THE STATE'S AUTHORITY
TO REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
SECURITY FOR ON SHORE OIL AND
GAS WELLS.
THIS BILL WINS WILL ENSURE THAT
TAXPAYERS ARE PROTECTED FROM
FINANCIAL LIABILITIES IN THE
EVENT A COMPANY FAILS TO FILL
THEIR LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
DECOMMISSION WHERE PRODUCTION
SITES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS THE MON.
SEEING HERE IN NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
OF MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE --
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
SQUIRES [inaudible]
FORTY ONE YEAH.
<c.cyan>G MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE</c>
.
IS THE MOON MOVE THE CALL
[inaudible]
MAKE --
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE
AB ONE FORTY TO THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AS A LEGAL ONE FORTY TO BUY
SOMETHING MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
NECKLINE HAZARDOUS WASTE MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE DECLINE
THIRDS EITHER UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER YES THANK
YOU IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
RE ALLOCATED A FEE ALREADY
IMPOSED ON ALL LEAD CAR
BATTERIES. TO FUND THE CLEANUP
COSTS BY LEAD ACID BATTERIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE HAVE HEARD A LOT ABOUT EXIDE
BUT THERE'S ACTUALLY FIFTEEN
OTHER IDENTIFIED SMELTERS WE
HAVE ONE HERE AND WAS SACRAMENTO
WE HAVE A LARGE ONE IN FRESNO
ALAMEDA SAN FRANCISCO OAKLAND
BRISBANE IN A NUMBER OF LA
CITIES AS WELL.
THIS FUND HEALTH CAN UP ALL OF
THESE SITES ACROSS THE STATE.
AB ONE FORTY TO ADDRESS THIS
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
PROGRAM.
IN ADDITION A REMOVED A SENSE
THAT ON THE MANUFACTURE FEE AND
ENSURES THAT THE PROGRAM REMAINS
EQUITABLE BY KEEPING AN EQUAL
AMOUNT BETWEEN THE CONSUMER FEE.
AND THE MANUFACTURE FEE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN ABLE
TO ENSURE THAT WE KEEP FAMILIES
HEALTHY CHILDREN HEALTHY -- AND
WE DON'T ALLOW ANOTHER
GENERATION CONTINUE TO BE HARMED
BY THE HORRIBLE EFFECTS OF LEAD
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GARCIA S. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS.
MATTER MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUED.
DO WORK ON THIS SPELL -- AND AND
BILLS ASSOCIATED WITH.
WITH THE CATASTROPHE THAT'S
HAPPENED IN MY DISTRICT IN HER
DISTRICT AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE PARTICULAR RELATING TO
LEAD POISONING.
AS WE ALL KNOW THIS BILL WITH
JESS TO REALLOCATE A FEE THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN IMPOSED OUR CAR
BATTERIES TO FUND THE CLEANUP OF
CONTAMINATION SITES LIKE THOSE.
LIKE THOSE MENTIONED BY THE BY
THE AUTHOR LIKE THOSE IN MY
DISTRICT HER DISTRICT AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB. ONE FORTY
TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MISS
GARCIA.
SELECT CLOSE NO THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES FIFTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY VOTE EYES FIFTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
ICE FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN ON
THE URGENCY.
I FIFTY FOUR NO THIRTEEN ON THE
BILL THE MEASURE PASSES.
PREPARE TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE
ITEM TWO THIRTY TWO A. B. TEN
FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY VOTE ICE FORTY THREE KNOWS
EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT AB
NINE SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE AND ACTUALLY TO PAROLE.
MR STERN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THAT YOU THE FENDER PRO PROGRAM
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. FOR THE PROBLEM IS
THOUGH THAT THOSE.
FOLKS WHO COULD COULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A DO NOT GET.
EARN CREDITS UNDER PROP FIFTY
SEVEN CREDIT PROGRAM.
THE WAY THEY ORDER IN THE
CHAMBER PLEASE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
WOULD ALLOW.
THOSE WHO ARE.
YOUTHFUL THERE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE TO
EARN CREDITS UNDER THE PROP
FIFTY SEVEN CREDIT SYSTEM WHY
THAT'S IMPORTANT IS THE CREDIT
SYSTEM INCENTIVIZE IS PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN PRISON. TO GO TO THE
PROGRAM THE TO DO THE WORK THAT
THEY NEED TO DO THAT REDUCES
RECIDIVISM RECIDIVISM RATE IN
CALIFORNIA IS 5060% WHICH IS
VERY UNFORTUNATE YOU THE THUNDER
PAROLE IS DOWN THAT THE
RECIDIVISM RATE FOR THOSE WHO DO
GET OUT.
UNDER YOUTH OFFENDER PAROLE IS
IN THE SINGLE DIGITS THAT'S WHAT
SHOWS THAT IT'S VERY VERY
SUCCESSFUL.
THIS IS A PROGRAM THAT WORKS BUT
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS A LINE OF
CREDIT SYSTEM TO KEEP PROVIDING
THOSE INCENTIVES.
SO THOSE WHO ARE IN THE YOUTH
OFFENDER PAROLE PROGRAM DO THE
CLASSES DO THE WORK SO THAT THAT
IF THEY DO GET OUT THEY WILL BE
MORE SUCCESSFUL.
THIS DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT
ANYONE WHO WAS OFFENDED WILL GET
OUT ALL IT DOES IS ENSURE IS
THAT THEY HAVE ARE MOTIVATED TO
DO THE WORK SO THAT WHEN THEY
MAKE A PAROLE HEARING.
THEY CAN PUT THEIR BEST FOOT
FORWARD AND THEN IF THEY DO GET
OUT THROUGH THAT PAROLE PROCESS
THAT THEY WILL BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL IN OUR COMMUNITIES
LEADING TO SAFER COMMUNITIES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
OF MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED ABOUT
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES FORTY TWO
NEWS TWENTY THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE A. B.
NINE THIRTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND ACTUALLY OIL SPILLS.
MR RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE
SIX SEEKS TO HELP PREVENT
CONTAIN AND MITIGATE.
SPILLS OF NON FLOATING OILS NOW
PROPOSES SAFETY MEASURES THAT
WILL HELP PROTECT TWELVE HUNDRED
MILES OF CALIFORNIA COASTLINE.
AND PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
MORE AND MORE HEAVY CRUDES LIKE
CANADIAN TAR SANDS OIL CRUDE
STOCKS FROM VENEZUELA AND MEXICO
ARE BEING TRANSPORTED TO OUR
STATE.
A TRANSPORTED BY WAY OF PIPELINE
AND TANKER.
AND BECAUSE OF OUR LOCATION AND
SPECIALIZED REFINING CAPACITY.
CALIFORNIA IS A DESTINATION FOR
NEW SUPPLIES OF NON FLOATING OIL.
THE CURRENT STATE LAW IT DOESN'T
OFFICIALLY ACCOUNT FOR SPILLS OF
NON POLLUTING OIL.
AND THIS GREAT SIGNIFICANT RISK
FOR OUR STATE AND IN PARTICULAR
RISK FOR OUR COASTAL LOCALITIES.
IN OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THIS IS IMPORTANT THIS GAP IN
STATE LAW REQUIRES OUR ATTENTION
IN A REQUIRES OUR ACTION SAFETY
AND PREPAREDNESS AROUND THIS
ISSUE IS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
AND WE CAN LEARN FROM THE STATE
OF MICHIGAN.
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN A
RUPTURE.
RUPTURED PIPELINE RESULTED IN A
SPILL INTO THE KALAMAZOO RIVER.
A SPILL OF MORE THAN ONE MILLION
GALLONS OF NON FLOATING CANADIAN
TAR SANDS OIL.
CITED AS THE LARGEST OIL SPILL
YOU HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
REMEDIATION OF THIS BILL TOOK
FIVE YEARS AND COST OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS.
ACCORDING TO US AGENCIES TOTAL
CLEANUP PROVED IMPOSSIBLE AND
CONTAMINATION REMAINS TO THIS
DAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE SIX IS
ABOUT SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS.
IT MANDATES AN UPDATE OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONTINGENCY
PLANNING. TO ENSURE THAT THE
OFFICE OF SPILL PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE OSCAR IS ADEQUATELY
PREPARED TO DEAL WITH SPILLS OF
THESE NON POLLUTING OILS.
OILS MOST LIKELY TO CAUSE
LASTING DAMAGE TO OUR MARINE
ENVIRONMENT OUR WATER RATES ARE
WATERWAYS AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
I HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH
THE OIL INDUSTRY ON THIS ISSUE
ON THIS BILL IN PARTICULAR.
THIS LEGISLATION ISN'T ABOUT
BANNING IMPORTS OF NON FORTY
OILS TO OUR REFINERIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BUT RATHER AGAIN IT'S ABOUT
SAFETY IT'S ABOUT PREPAREDNESS.
IT'S ABOUT INSTITUTING MEASURES
MEASURES VERY SIMILAR TO THE
STATE OF WASHINGTON TO PROTECT
THE SAFETY AND HEALTH OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OUR COASTLINES IN
OUR WATERS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED ABOUT
THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTED
DESERVE A THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY TWO KNOWS FIFTEEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB FIFTEEN
NINETY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
AND ACTUALLY IT TAXATION MAKING
PROBATION THEREFORE.
MISS REST YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SHOULD I PRESENT TO YOU
AB.
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE A BILL
WHICH BUILDS ON THE SUCCESS OF
THE CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT.
OR KELLY I TO SEE BY ALLOWING
INDIVIDUALS WITH FEDERAL I
DIDN'T FEDERAL.
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS ALSO
KNOWN AS ITUNES TO QUALIFY FOR
THE CREDIT.
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE SUPPORTED
I KELLY I TO SEE AS WELL AS
EXPANSIONS OF THE CREDIT.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE LEFT MANY.
OUT OF OUR IMMIGRANT.
HAS LEFT OUT MANY OF OUR
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THE BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND STATE BUDGET SENATE
BUDGET SUB COMMITTEES HAVE
LOOKED AT AS IT IS CLEAR THAT
IMMIGRANTS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS KEY MEMBERS OF COMMUNITIES
PAYING BILLIONS ANNUALLY IN
STATE AND LOCAL TAXES DESERVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BENEFIT FROM THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM.
AB FIFTEEN NINETY THREE PROVIDES
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY FOR TAXPAYERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WRASSE SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERTED
ROADS.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
VOTES.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE
.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT AB
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL EIGHT TWENTY FOUR
BY SOMETHING MEMBER WOULD AND
ACTUALLY THE BUSINESS.
SIR WOULD YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
MOST OF YOU KNOW THE COST
CONTAINMENT AND AFFORDABILITY OF
HEALTH CARE HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR ME SINCE
JOINING THE LEGISLATURE.
AND EVERY YEAR.
I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE FOUGHT
AGAINST THE RISING COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS COST TO
CONTRIBUTE UP 220% OF TODAY'S
HEALTHCARE COSTS. TO THAT END I
BRING.
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR TODAY SOME
DRUG COMPANIES USE A PRACTICE OF
PAPER DELAY WHERE THEY MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS WITH GENERIC
COMPANIES TO DELAY THE
PRODUCTION OF LESS EXPENSIVE
GENERIC DRUGS IN ORDER TO
MAINTAIN.
THEIR HIGHER PROFITS EVEN AFTER
THE PATENTS EXPIRE.
AB EIGHT TWENTY FOUR WILL
ENCOURAGE THE ENTRY OF DRUG
GENERIC DRUGS INTO THE MARKET AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE AFTER BRAND
NAME PATENTS EXPIRES.
THIS BILL ESTABLISH A
PRESUMPTION THAT THESE TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS ARE ANTI COMPETITIVE
AND IT WILL ALLOW BRAND ENGINEER
COMPANIES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVE THAT THESE AGREEMENTS ARE
PRO COMPETITIVE.
I'M CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
DRUG MANUFACTURERS ON THEIR
CONCERN AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
ACCEPTED TO ALLOW FOR
SETTLEMENTS THAT AT THE SAME
TIME WILL PROTECT CONSUMERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER WOULD SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED
ABOUT THIS REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE YEAH WORK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE AYE
AYES FORTY FOUR NEWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY AB THIRTEEN
TWELVE THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN TWELVE BY
SOME REMEMBER LOW AND ACTUALLY
PROFESSIONS APPLICATIONS.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BEEN A SECRET MEMBERS AB.
THIRTEEN TWELVE REQUIRES THE
SECRETARY STATE TO COME UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR BEST
PRACTICES ON REGISTRATION FOR
COLLEGE CONSULTANTS TO ENSURE
THAT WE HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. FOR THOSE INVOLVED
IN MAKING MONEY FOR THOSE
CONTROL INTO HIGHER EDUCATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOS SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FORTY FOUR
KNOWS TO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO TWENTY ONE AB FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SOME THE MEMBER EGGMAN AND
OTHERS AND ACTING TO MATERNAL
HEALTH.
THIS EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB FIVE SEVEN SEVEN IS HERE --
THAT DEALS WITH MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH THIS IS A WOMAN.
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL THIS BILL
IT SAYS THAT WHEN WOMEN RUN OUT
OF MEDICAL AFTER SIXTY DAYS OF
THEIR SUFFERING FROM SOME MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE OR POST FROM
DEPRESSION THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE
TO EXTEND THEIR MEDI CAL OR
COVERED CALIFORNIA. FOR UP TO A
FULL YEAR WE KNOW THAT HEALTHY
MOMS MAKE HEALTHY KIDS AND THAT
POSITIVE MENTAL HEALTH IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF OVERALL
HEALTH AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PRIORITY BILL.
THANK YOU MISS EGGMAN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTERS.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
WORK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I FIFTY NINE NEWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN BY LINE TO
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY FIFTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BY FAMILY MEMBER RAMOS AND
CTUALLY GET APPRENTICESHIP.
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT THIS BILL
REQUIRES A SCHOOL OR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY TO CONTACT
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PRECEDING A COLLEGE OR CAREER
FAIR.
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE MADE
AWARE OF AND HAVE ACCESS TO
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS SERVE A
VARIETY OF IMPORTANT PURPOSES.
BY BOTH EXPANDING THE SKILLED
WORKFORCE AND PROVIDING
APPRENTICE COMPETITIVE WAGES
THAT EARNED AS YOU LEARN MODEL
HAS PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
TO THE JOB MARKET FOR ALL
WORKERS.
WELL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
HAVE A CLEAR BENEFIT FOR
STUDENTS THE CURRENT ACADEMIC
CLIMATE IN HIGH SCHOOLS OFTEN
EMPHASIZES COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS
WHILE THE BENEFITS AND
OPPORTUNITIES OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS FOR STUDENTS.
EXITING HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
COMMONLY OVERLOOKED.
EVEN IF STUDENTS WERE PROVIDED
THE INFORMATION ON THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THEY ARE OFTEN UNAWARE
OF WHAT LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE AVAILABLE IN THE
LOCAL AREAS.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT REQUIRES
A SCHOOL OUR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO CONTACT LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PROCEEDING OF COLLEGE ARE CAREER
FAIR.
THIS ENSURES THAT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE GIVEN THE SAME
FORUMS TO PRESENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO STUDENTS AS OTHER COLLEGE ARE
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO IMPROVE
CHANNELS OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
AND APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BY
PROVIDING POINTS OF CONTACT AND
LOCATIONS OF OPERATION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
THIS PRACTICE WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE MADE AWARE OF THE
BENEFITS OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN THE SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATING WITH
REGIONAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
COORDINATORS AS PARTNERS IN
MOVIES TO IT STUDENTS TOWARD
PRODUCTIVE CAREERS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MISTER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK MADAM SPEAKER --
I JUST WANNA RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT -- THIS IS REALLY VERY
VERY IMPORTANT I KNOW IT SOUNDS
LIKE THIS SHOULD HAVE BEEN DONE
A LONG TIME AGO.
BUT I THANK OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN BERNADINO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD -- MY OLDEST SON IS YOU
KNOW -- AND OPTED FROM VIETNAM --
AND IS A PLUMBING CONTRACTOR
TODAY -- IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE HE WAS ABLE TO BE
INTRODUCED THAT THAT KIND OF AN
OPTION HE WAS NOT HEADED TO
COLLEGE BUT HE HAS BEEN HEADED
TO SUCCESS.
EVER SINCE BECAUSE OF THINGS
LIKE THIS I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR BRINGING IT FORWARD I
STRONGLY.
SUPPORT IT AND I HOPE THIS GETS
SUCH HUGE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE MISTER RAMOS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU SB RIVAL WORK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TELEVOTE I
SEVENTY NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
I LET HIM TO TWENTY THREE A. B.
NINE ELEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ELEVEN BY
SILLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES.
TO RODRIGUEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MAP THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARE RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
ELEVEN KNOWN AS THE MANY ALERT
ACT.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO EIGHT
MILLION PERSONS WERE OLDER
ADULTS OR PERSONS WITH MOBILITY
CENTURY INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES OR
THOSE EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS.
INDIVIDUALS ARE CONSIDERED AT
RISK MAY HAVE UNIQUE NEEDS
REQUIRE SPECIAL ACCOMMODATIONS
ESPECIALLY DURING CASES OF
EMERGENCY OR THERE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO CLEARLY COMMUNICATE WITH
FIRST RESPONDERS.
IN ORDER TO BEST SERVE AT RISK
INDIVIDUALS OR MINIMIZE ANY RISK
OF INJURY.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT OFFERS
RESPOND HERS FIRE LAW
ENFORCEMENT EMS BE PROVIDED WITH
THE PERSON'S.
VITAL HEALTH INFORMATION PRIOR
TO ARRIVING TO SING.
MEMBERS THIS WILL BE A SYSTEM
THAT WILL HELP KEEP OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS SAFER.
AND BETTER PREPARE FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE STRICTLY OUTRIGHT
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOUGH TWO THIRDS
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DISCARD VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY TWO KNOWS
YOUR THIS MEASURE PASSES BY
LIGHT INTO TWENTY FOUR AB TEN
NINETY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN NINETY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY THE WATER QUALITY
MISS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO PRESENTE
BE.
TEN NINETY THREE THIS BILL WILL
HELP OUR CITIES AND COUNTIES --
CONTINUE TO WORK ON AND NAVIGATE
SOME WATER COST CHALLENGES
STORMWATER COSTS ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH AND MANY OF OUR CITIES THAT
WILL CREATE FINANCIAL
INSTABILITY.
BRADBURY IS A CITY IN MY
DISTRICT BECAUSE A SAYS RATE
REGIONAL WATER BOARD PERMIT FEES
ARE ALMOST TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS ALMOST THIRTY
FOUR TIMES THEIR ANNUAL BUDGET.
MEMBERS THIS BILL WILL HELP OUR
CITIES AND COUNTIES CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE CALIFORNIA'S A
STATE WATER BOARD TO FIND
SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES.
AMENDMENTS WERE ADDED BY
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THIS
BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
IN POLICY COMMITTEE THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
COACH.
BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SEVEN NEWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES WILL PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEMS.
TO TWENTY FIVE TWO TWO TWENTY
EIGHT FILE ITEM TO TWENTY NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY FOR THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS LEGAL EIGHT THIRTY FOUR BY
SELLING MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY WATER QUALITY.
MR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
ARE AB.
THREE SHE'S ME AB EIGHT THREE
FOUR DIRECTS THE STATE WATER
BOARD TO MAINTAIN.
MINIMAL RECREATIONAL FRESH WATER
SAFETY STANDARDS AND ESTABLISH A
FRESH WATER IN ESTHER WINE
HARMFUL ALGAL BLOOM PROGRAM --
THESE AL GUY PRODUCE TOXINS THAT
THREATEN HUMAN HEALTH AS WELL AS
SAYS HIS PATHS AND SEE OTTERS --
INCLUDING -- LIKE SHOULD BOW IN
MY OWN DISTRICT.
MEASURES ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AS NO OPPOSITION I ASK
THE ARRIVE OF THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER PARK SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY FOUR
KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
PASS TEMPORARILY AND VIOLATING
TO THIRTY FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY NINE FIFTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ AS A LEGAL NINE
FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY THE WATER.
MR GIPSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT -- A. B.
NINE FIFTY FIVE WHICH SEEKS TO
PRO PROVIDE A WATER
REPLENISHMENT.
ORDER IN THE CHAMBER PLEASE.
THANK YOU THE WATER PUT IS
REDUCING KNOWN AS W. R. D. --
WITH THE RESOURCES TO CONDUCT A
REGIONAL ASSESSMENT OF WATER
SYSTEMS ACROSS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TERRITORY MANY OF YOU
KNOW THAT I HAD TO I HAD A
SPELLING WATER DISTRICT IN BY.
A DISTRICT THAT WE HAD TO PUT A
BRING LEGISLATION ON ONLY TO
REMOVE THE ELECTED BODY BUT ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT THE RESIDENTS OF
THAT AREA.
HAD CLEAN DRINKING WATER -- WELL
THIS WAS NECESSARY DUE TO THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AT THAT AT THIS AT
BALANCE HAVE TO BALANCE BETWEEN
A LOCAL CONTROL AND WATER
QUALITY.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO DO A
STUDY IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION TO MAKING SURE THE
SMALLER WATER AGENCIES.
CAN ACTUALLY DELIVER QUALITY
DRINKING WATER TO THE RESIDENCE
IN WHICH IT SERVES MEMBERS I AM
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON A. B..
NINE FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED YOU THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DISCARD VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY WILL NOT SIXTY
NINE TO ALLOW AUTHORS TO TAKE UP
LATE AMENDMENTS ON THE FOLLOWING
BILLS OUT OF FOURTEEN AB THIRTY
SIX IN GALLAGHER AND ITEM TWENTY
SIX A. B. SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO
SHALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB SIXTEEN SIXTY
NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS BY SOME REMEMBER
BONTA.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES ARTS RESENTMENTS AB
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE IS A MOMENT
STRIKE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD.
HAVE RAISED THE DEALER RECORD OF
SELFIE KNOWN AS THE DRAW SPEAK
TO THIRTY TWO DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN CENTS.
ADDITIONALLY THE AMENDMENTS
AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO CHARGE A FEE.
OF THIRTEEN DOLLARS AND NINETEEN
CENTS PER FIRE ARMS RELATED
TRANSACTIONS SOLELY TO COVER THE
COSTS.
OF ITS FIRE ARMS RELATED
REGULATORY AND ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT THESE AMENDMENTS BE
ADOPTED.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA MISTER
FLORA THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER WE OPPOSE ASK FOR A ROLL
CALL VOTE.
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
ABOUT THIS IS ON AMENDMENTS.
MISTER CALDERON ASPIRIN AYE VOTE
MISTER FLORA ASKS FOR NO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS I HEARD
ABOUT MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS MISTER FLOOR IS
ASKING FOR AN NO VOTES.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
FOUR KNOWS.
SIXTEEN THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED.
THEY'RE OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GALLAGHER.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER -- THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS SOME CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT UP IN IN
COMMITTEE AND IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH OTHER MEMBERS -- THIS BILL
AGAIN AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN WOULD
PROHIBIT A SOCIAL MEDIA SITE
FROM BLOCKING CONTENT PURELY
BASED ON IT'S POLITICAL IDEOLOGY
BUT THESE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT.
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES WOULD BE ABLE
TO CONTINUE TO BLOCK -- ANYTHING
THAT IS OBSCENE THREATENING OR
HARASSING ADVOCATING VIOLENCE.
OR PURPORTS TO STATE FACTUAL
INFORMATION THAT IS DEMONSTRABLY
FALSE.
I IT ALSO HAS PROVISIONS IN
THESE AMENDMENTS.
THAT ALLOW A SOCIAL MEDIA SITE
TO BLOCK CONTACT WHEN THEIR
TERMS AND CONDITIONS.
CLEARLY STATE THAT IT IS ONLY
SEEKING.
CERTAIN POLITICAL VIEWPOINTS OR
IF THERE IS AN INCONSISTENCY
WITH.
THE SITE'S.
COMMUNITY VALUES -- SO AT THAT
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR THESE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF THE
AMENDMENT SAY I ALL OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT BACK TO
FILE.
FILE ITEM. TWENTY SIX AB.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO MR CHOW YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WITH A MOMENT BY SOMETHING
MEMBER CHILD MR CHOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON PRESENTING AMENDMENTS.
FOR AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE
AMENDMENTS DEFINE THE TERM
ANONYMIZED DELETE THE TERM
SUFFICIENTLY AND ALSO PROVIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THE ABILITY TO
RETAIN A L. P. R. DATA.
PAST SIXTY DAYS IF IT'S BEING
USED AS EVIDENCE OR IN THE
FELONY INVESTIGATION AS AMERICAN
VEHICLE CODE SECTION TWENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU MR CHOW WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE ADOPTION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR OF
THE AMENDMENT SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK TO
FILE.
FILE ITEM THIRTY THREE AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
THIS RACE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TO THEM PRESENTING AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENT TO AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
OPPOSITION CONCERNS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS REST WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE ADOPTION OF THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK TO
FILE.
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE WITH
AMENDMENTS BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ.
MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I TOOK THESE AMENDMENTS
YESTERDAY THERE THE SAME
AMENDMENTS OR WAS SIMPLY A
DRAFTING ERROR AND I HOPE TO
CORRECT THOSE IN THESE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK TO
FILE -- FILE ITEM ONE OH NINE AB
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN IS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF A MAN.
THANK YOU MINUTES BAKER I RISE
TODAY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDING AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
THESE MEMBERS WOULD REMOVE THE
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION AND
CHANGE THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
TO THE PROPER POLICY COMMITTEES
IN BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE.
I REQUEST WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE NAY MOMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
ADOPTION OF THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAME.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK TO
FILE.
YEAH.
WE ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL
ON FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL THOSE WHO DIED -- PLEASE
VOTE.
ALL THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
PLEASE VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY FOUR NO.
SEVENTEEN THIS MEASURES ADOPTED.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB SIX
SEVENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL
READ SOMETHING ALL SIX SEVENTY
THREE WITH THE MEMONS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
MISS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE AMENDMENTS. TO AB
THINK SEVENTY THREE WILL REMOVE
THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION.
AND THAT'S ADDRESS OUR
OPPOSITIONS CONCERNS THE TH
AMENDMENT ALSO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT EITHER THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER CAN COLLECTED CIVIL
PENALTY OR THE WORKER CAN
RECOVER A STATUTORY PENALTY BUT
NOT BOTH.
THUS WORKERS WILL BE ABLE TO
ACCESS TO AVENUES TO REMEDY LATE
PAYMENTS AS THEY DO IN CURRENT
LAW.
THOUGH AN ADMINISTRATIVE ACTION
OR THROUGH THE PRIVATE RIGHT
PRIVATE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ACT
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS PAGO I RISK
OF RESPECTFULLY REQUEST OF THE
TH AMENDMENT TO BE ADOPTED.
THE BILL WAS SENT OUT TO PRINT
AND PLACE BACK ON THE FILE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR THE MA'AM AND SAY
AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TO EIGHTY
SIX NINETY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
A SINGLE SIX NINETY FOUR BY
SAMMY MEMBER IRWIN AND ACTUALLY
THE VETERANS HOUSING BY
EVERYBODY THE FUNDS NECESSARY
THERE FOR THREE ELECTION FOR THE
ISSUANCE AND SALE BONDS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
HANDLING A DISPOSITION OF THOSE
FUNDS.
MR WHEN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AS WE ENTER ENTER INTO
THE MEMORIAL DAY WEEKEND IT IS.
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT THAT I GET
YOUR SUPPORT ON AB.
SIX NINE FOR WHICH AN AXE THE
VETERANS HOUSING AND HOMELESS
PREVENTION BOND ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN TO AUTHOR.
AUTHORIZE THE ISSUANCE OF BONDS
TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FOR CONSTRUCTING AFFORDABLE
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING WAS
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION.
TWELVE THE VETERANS BOND ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AUTHORIZING
NINE HUNDRED MILLION IN GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS TO HELP
VETERANS PURCHASE SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES FARMS AND MOBILE HOMES.
IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN AB SIX
THREE AND NINE RESTRUCTURED THE
BOND ACT AUTHORIZING SIX HUNDRED
MILLION AN EXISTING BOND
AUTHORITY TO FUND MULTI FAMILY
HOUSING. FOR THAT IT VETERANS
AND CREATING V. H. H. P..
OVER FOUR ROUNDS OF FUNDING V.
H. H. P. HAS PROVIDED TWO
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
TWO TOTAL HOUSING UNITS FOR
VETERANS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THERE'S NOW ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
NINETY MILLION LEFT A ATA RATE
OF SEVENTY FIVE FOR AROUND THE
FUNDING WILL RUN RUN OUT IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
VOTE IN TWENTY TWENTY TO
CONTINUE FUNDING THE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM -- AN ESTIMATED TWELVE
THOUSAND HOMELESS VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA AND EVEN MORE
EXPERIENCING HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
SO -- AB SIX NINE FOUR WILL
ASSIST VETERANS WHO ARE HOMELESS
OR WHO NEED -- TO WHO NEED
AFFORDABLE RENTAL HOUSING TO
ENSURE HOUSING FOR THEMSELVES
AND THEIR FAMILIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU MISS IRWIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY FOUR AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AS A REGIONAL BILL TO
ADDRESS A HOUSING CRISIS IN THE
BAY AREA.
UNFORTUNATELY THE BAY AREA HAS
CONTINUE TO BE THE EPICENTER OF
OUR STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WITH
RECORD HOME PRICES RENTS
EVICTIONS AND HOMELESSNESS.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL EFFORTS OF A
HUNDRED AND ONE BAY AREA CITIES
IN NINE COUNTIES HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
THE BILL ENABLES THE BAY AREA TO
HELP ITSELF GIVEN THE NINE
COUNTY REGION THE SORTIE TO
RAISE AFFORDABLE HOUSING FUNDING
SIMILAR TO HOW OUR REGION HAS
AUTHORITY TO RAISE MONIES FOR
TRANSPORTATION.
AND SAN FRANCISCO BAY
RESTORATION THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
REGIONAL HOUSING ENTITY TO
ASSIST LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IN
PLANNING FOR PRODUCTION
PRESERVATION PROTECTION A SYMBOL
PARCELS AND MONITOR REGIONAL
PROGRESS.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH%
REGIONAL LEADERS TO DETERMINE
THE BEST WAY TO DISTRIBUTE AND
EXPAND REVENUES AND EXPECTATIVAS
IN THE SENATE BASED ON THEIR
INPUT.
THIS BILL WOULD EMPOWER THE BAY
AREA TO FINALLY ADDRESS A
REGIONAL HOUSING CRISIS IN WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTES.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
TWO NEWS EIGHTEEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS IN [inaudible]
FILE ORDER.
CORRECTION.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP.
THE ASSISTANT PRO TEM'S BILLS.
THIS IS MISS BY OUR QUE HAN.
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM.
NINETY TWO AB.
EIGHT TEN EIGHTY SIX CARILLO.
ASSEMBLY WILL TEN EIGHTY SIX BY
SELLING OVER BARRICADE HAN AND
ACTUALLY TO AGRICULTURE.
MS BARRETT CAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AB.
TEN EIGHTY SIX THIS BILL WILL
AID SMALL FARMERS TO CONVERT TO
HIGHER EFFICIENCY IRRIGATION
SYSTEMS BY CODIFYING IN
IMPROVING THESE EXISTING STATE
WATER EFFICIENCY AND ENHANCEMENT
PROGRAM.
ALSO KNOWN AS SWEEPS.
CALIFORNIA'S SEVENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FARMS ARE CRITICAL TO
THE STATE'S AGRICULTURAL AND
RURAL ECONOMIES.
AS WELL AS THE STATE'S WATER
STEWARDSHIP.
IN RESPONSE TO THE DOUBT DROUGHT
CRISIS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THIS%
STATE CREATED THE SWEEPS PROGRAM
TO SUPPORT ON FARM IRRIGATION
MANAGEMENT PROJECTS THAT IMPROVE
WATER USE EFFICIENCY WHILE
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE ADMINISTERS SWEEP
WHICH PROVIDES INCENTIVE GRANTS
TO FARMERS TO TRANSITION TO MORE
WATER AND ENERGY EFFICIENT
IRRIGATION SYSTEMS WILL
ACHIEVING MULTIPLE CO BENEFITS
INCLUDING REDUCED ENERGY AND
WATER COSTS.
INCREASE PRODUCTION REDUCE
NITRATE CONTAMINATION OF WATER
IMPROVED AIR QUALITY AND
ENHANCED RESILIENCY TO DROUGHT.
MEMBERS AS WE DISCUSS OFTEN IN
THIS BODY EVERY CALIFORNIAN
DESERVES CLEAN WATER AN ADEQUATE
AMOUNT OF WATER AND THIS BILL
WILL HELP US GET THERE.
SWEEP HAS BEEN A HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL AND POPULAR PROGRAM.
AND THIS BILL WILL HELP US
CONTINUE IT.
B TEN EIGHTY SIX IMPROVES ON
THIS WEEK'S PROGRAM BY
PRIORITIZING SWEEPS GRANTS FOR
SMALL AND MID SCALE FARMS OF
LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED ACRES AND
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED FARMERS
AND RANCHERS.
FUNDING NECESSARY EDUCATIONAL
TRAININGS FOR IRRIGATION
OPERATORS TO MAXIMIZE THEIR
IRRIGATION AND NUTRIENT
MANAGEMENT EFFICIENCY.
AND FINDING INTEGRATED
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY AND
WATERED AND ENERGY EFFICIENCY
PILOT PROJECTS WITH IRRIGATION
DISTRICTS AND GROUNDWATER
SUSTAINABILITY AGENCIES I
REQUEST WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE IS BACK IN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM.
NINETY EIGHT THIS IS AB ELEVEN
SIXTY FIVE BY MISS BARRICADE
HAND CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN SIXTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BARRICADE HAN
AND ACTUALLY A CHILD CUSTODY.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
TODAY I PRESENT AB ELEVEN SIXTY
FIVE WHICH WILL HELP PROTECT
CHILDREN IN CUSTODY MATTERS BY
ENSURING THAT DURING COURT
ORDERED VISITATION.
MONITORS TASKED WITH SUPERVISING
THESE VISITS HAVE PASSED
APPROPRIATE BACKGROUND AND
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS.
IN CHILD CUSTODY MATTERS FAMILY
COURTS REQUIRE SUPERVISED
VISITATIONS WHEN THERE ARE
ALLEGATIONS OR HISTORY OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
NEGLECT SUBSTANCE ABUSE MENTAL
ILLNESS.
OR THREATS OF ADOPTION.
THE COURT WILL REQUIRE FOR
PROFESSIONAL MONITORS WHEN THERE
ARE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT CHILD
SAFETY.
CURRENT STATUTES REQUIRE
PROFESSIONAL PROVIDERS TO MEET
CERTAIN STANDARDS FOR EXAMPLE
THE PROVIDER HAS TO BE TWENTY
ONE YEARS OLD.
NOT BE CONVICTED OF A DO YOU AYE
WITHIN LAST. FIVE YEARS HAVE NO
RECORD OF CONVICTION. FOR CHILD
MOLESTATION AND RECEIVE TWENTY
FOUR HOURS OF TRAINING.
WELL THE ABOVE MENTIONED
TRAINING QUALIFICATIONS
CURRENTLY EXISTS THERE IS NO WAY
FOR A PARENT TO VERIFY WHETHER
THE REQUISITE TRAINING WAS
ACTUALLY COMPLETED AND THE
QUALIFICATIONS QUALIFICATIONS
HAVE BEEN MAPPED.
UNLIKE WHEN I GOING VOLUNTEER IN
MY CHILDREN'S CLASSROOM THERE IS
NO CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
THESE PEOPLE WHO COURTS ARE
ORDERING TO BE WITH CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE ONLY VERIFICATION CURRENTLY
REQUIRED IS FOR THE MONITOR TO
THEMSELVES FILL OUT A
DECLARATION UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THEY HAVE NOT
CONVICTED THESE CRIMES.
IN SOME CASES THAT FORM ISN'T
EVEN SUBMITTED TO ANYONE.
IN OTHER WORDS THERE IS NO WAY
FOR CALIFORNIANS PARENTS WERE
REQUIRED TO HIRE THESE MONITORS
TO ENSURE THAT THEIR CHILDREN TO
THE PATIENT.
IS BEING SUPERVISED BY SOMEONE
WHO HAS NOT BEEN CONVICTED OF A
SEXUAL FELONY.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY FIVE WILL PUT IN
PLACE REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
BACKGROUND CHECKS IN IN PERSON
TRAINING THEY MUST BE COMPLETED
IN PASSED BY THESE PROFESSIONAL
VISITATION MONITORS. TO BETTER
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
CHILDREN UNDER THEIR CARE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS BACK IN SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE WE HAVE SOME
VOTE CHANGES THAT WE ARE GOING
TO ENTERTAIN [inaudible]
SPECIFICALLY.
MR HOLE HOLDEN.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
FOR YOUR VOTE CHANGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER -- THIS
WOULD BE A MOTION TO RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE BY GALLAGHER HOLDEN
I'D TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOLDEN MOTION TO RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER I TO KNOW.
M. IS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED I
BLANCA RUBIO MOTION TO RE REFER
TO COMMITTEE FROM -- I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO
MOTION TO REFER TO COMMITTEE I
TO KNOW.
AND MEMBERS WE HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CITY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
DAY CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY -- SIXTEEN FIFTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AND
EXPLAIN TO THE LEGISLATURE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS REYES IRA TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SEVENTY SIX NO.
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED
AS FOR THE CHANGE.
MOTION TO YOUR REAR.
FOR REFERRED TO COMMITTEE IS
THAT CORRECT.
RE REFER TO COMMITTEE I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES.
MOTION TO RE REFER TO COMMITTEE
I TO KNOW.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
MONDAY MAY TWENTY SEVENTH IS A
HOLIDAY.
MEMORIAL DAY TUESDAY MAY TWENTY
EIGHTH WE WILL HAVE FLOOR
SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF AN OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
MEMBERS I ASK THAT YOU
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR ORTEGA'S SEATS SO WE CAN
MOVE TO GERMANS IN MEMORY
[inaudible]
THE FILE -- IS WERE GRANTED
PRIOR PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON IN
GERMANY MEMORY MISTER LACKEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER TODAY
ASKED WE DURING A MEMORY OF OLAF
LANDS GUARD.
A LEADER WITHIN THE ROLE OF A
COMMUNITY YOU PEACEFULLY PASSED
AWAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD.
OLAF WAS THE THIRD OF ELEVEN
CHILDREN AND GREW UP IN THE
SMALL TOWN OF ROSSMAN.
BEFORE I MOVED TO IDAHO TO
PURSUE A DEGREE IN SPEECH AND
DRAMA FROM THE LEWIS AND CLARK
COLLEGE.
IN A JURISDICTION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO.
HE WAS DEVOTED TO PUBLIC SERVICE
WHERE HE SERVED IN PART WITH THE
ROSE TO COMMUNITY SERVICE
DISTRICT.
ROSA MUNICIPAL ADVISORY COUNCIL.
SOUTHERN KERN.
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
ROSEMAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
IN ADDITION ALL OF WAS
INSTRUMENTAL THIS TALISMAN OF
THE ROSEWOOD URGENT CARE CLINIC.
ALL OF CREATED THE LEGACY.
OF COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT AND
CIVIC CONCERNED ALONG INSPIRE
THE CITIZENS AND RESIDENTS OF
ROSSMAN.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER.
SIBLINGS FIFTY THREE NIECES AND
NEPHEWS AND THE COMMUNITY THAT
HE DEVOTED HIS LIFE.
TO AND I ASKED YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY IN THE MEMORY OF ALL OFF
LANCE CARD.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
MISS CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN A MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
[inaudible]
JOSHUA EMMANUEL AGAIN THEY WAS
BORN AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN TWO
THOUSAND ONE IN HOLLYWOOD. TO
ANGEL AN OLDER GUY AND THEY AND
WAS A RESIDENT OF MY DISTRICT IN
EAGLE ROCK AND WENT TO EAGLE
ROCK HIGH SCHOOL.
JOSHUA WAS THE YOUNGEST OF SIX
SIBLINGS WHICH INCLUDED TWO
BROTHERS ANTHONY AND BILLY.
AND THREE SISTERS LISETTE LENA
AND GLORIA.
AT FOUR YEARS OLD HE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH AUTISM.
JOSHUA WAS A BRIGHT CHILD
EVIDENCED BY HIS ABILITY TO
UNLOCK ANY CHILD PROOF OBSTACLE
HE FACED.
AND TO MAKE ANYTHING OUT OF
LEGOS WITHOUT INSTRUCTIONS.
HE WAS ALWAYS SMILING HE LOVE
ROAD TRIPS HE BAKED BROWNIES AND
CHOCOLATE CAKES AND HE ENJOYED
DANCING SINGING AND LISTENING TO
MUSIC.
GROWING UP JOSH WAS DIED WITH
HIS MOVIE BUDDY.
AND HE LOOK UP FINALLY TO HIS
BROTHER'S.
JOSHUA WAS ALSO DEVOTED TO HIS
BELIEFS OFTEN SHARING THE THINGS
HE LEARNED FROM THE BIBLE WITH
PEOPLE OF HIS COMMUNITY
[inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
JOSHUA TOOK HIS OWN LIFE ON
TUESDAY APRIL SECOND.
WHICH WAS ALSO NATIONAL AUTISM
AWARENESS DAY.
HE CHOSE TO LEAVE THIS WORLD ON
THAT DAY.
BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN DEALING.
WITH BEING BULLIED AT SCHOOL.
WHICH 20% OF HIGH SCHOOL KIDS IN
OUR NATION DEAL WITH EVERY DAY.
AND HE FELT A SENSE OF
DESPERATION.
IN NEEDING TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THE BOWLING HE WAS EXPERIENCING.
WE OWE IT TO JOSHUA.
IN ALL OUR STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS TO DO WHATEVER WE CAN TO
ENSURE THEY LEAVE THE LIVE
JOYFUL LIVES.
AND NOT HAVE TO WORRY.
ABOUT BEING BULLIED.
JOSH WAS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER
OLGA HIS FATHER ANGEL HIS
BROTHERS.
AND HIS HIS BROTHER ANTHONY AND
HIS WIFE AND ANGELICA HIS
BROTHER BILLY AND HIS WIFE
JUDITH AND THEIR CHILDREN LOUIS
KAREN AND THEN YEAH Là.
HIS SISTER LISSETTE.
AND THEIR SON'S NECK AND BRENDAN.
AND HIS SISTER LENA.
AND HER HUSBAND LARRY HIS SISTER
GLORIA.
AND HER HUSBAND GREG AND THEIR
SON EVAN AND THEIR DAUGHTER EVA.
MEMBERS I ASK THAT WE INTERNET
JOSHUA'S MEMORY AND THAT YOU
JOIN ME IN PLEDGING TO DO
WHATEVER IS WITHIN OUR POWERS.
TO PROTECT ALL OF OUR CHILDREN.
THROUGHOUT THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO MISTER
RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER -- I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR LEONARD BAILEY.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON MAY TWELFTH
AT THE AGE OF?
SEVENTY SIX DOCTOR BAILEY WAS A
RESIDENT OF REDLANDS AND WORKED
AS A PEDIATRIC CARDIAC SURGEON.
AT LOMA LINDA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL.
HE WAS BORN ON AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTH NINETEEN FORTY TWO IN
TAKOMA PARK MARYLAND. TO NELSON
BAILEY THE CHAFF.
AND KATHLEEN BAILEY A NURSE.
HE GRADUATED FROM COLUMBIA UNION
COLLEGE AND EARNED HIS MEDICAL
DEGREE FROM LOMA LINDA
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF MEDICINE IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE DOCTOR
BAILEY WENT ON TO PIONEER HUMAN
HEART TRANSPLANTS FOR INFANTS.
AND TO BUILD A RENOWNED CENTER
FOR CHILDREN'S CARDIAC SURGERY
AT LOMA LINDA UNIVERSITY.
HE REMAINED BEST KNOWN TO THE
PUBLIC.
AS A DOCTOR BEHIND THE STORY OF
THE INFINITE KNOWN AS BABY FAY.
ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR HE
PERFORMED THE FIRST BABOON TO
HUMAN HEART TRANSPLANT ON BABY
FAY.
BABYFACE SURVIVE FOR TWENTY ONE
DAYS.
BUT HER CASE HELPED FOCUS
CONCERN ON THE PLIGHT OF BABIES
BORN WITH FETAL HEART DEFECTS IN
THE NEED FOR ORGANS.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE DR
BAILEY PERFORMED THE FIRST
SUCCESSFUL.
INFANT INFANT HEART TRANSPLANT.
HE WENT ON TO PERFORM THREE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MORE.
SURGERIES OVER HIS CAREER.
INCLUDING SIX THOUSAND NON
TRANSPLANT SURGERIES SAVING
THOUSANDS OF YOUNG CHILDREN'S
LIVES UNTIL HE RETIRED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DOCTOR
LEONARD BAILEY WAS KNOWN FOR HIS
KINDNESS.
LADY CHARACTER IN LOVE FOR
CHILDREN.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS TWO SONS
BROOKS AND CONNOR.
ALONG WITH TWO GRANDDAUGHTERS
AND HIS SISTER JOAN BAILEY.
I ASKED THAT WE A JUROR IN THE
MEMORY OF DOCTOR LETTER BAILEY A
TRUE PIONEER IN THE FIELD OF
MEDICINE.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS
TO BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED INTERCHANGE ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED SEEING AND
HEARING NO.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISTER
GALLAGHER SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
TUESDAY MAY TWENTY EIGHTH AT ONE
PM